[Music]
fireball came out of absolutely nowhere
and then it became something that was
behind every bar I had never heard of it
and within a month I didn't know a
person that didn't drink it it was that
quick
I remember that vendor coming in when
you're playing on the bar to throw on
the bar and use this explosion it's a
very very smooth easy shot I think it
works for women because it's on the
sweeter side for guys and still
qualifies as a whiskey the crowd-pleaser
shop for everyone
fireball whiskey is very syrupy very
high in sugar you take a shot and the
first thing you get is you get a little
bit of heat and then the sweetness
happens and on the back end it kind of
tastes like you have big red gum in your
mouth I do remember the first time I
tasted that I'm going it's not that bad
you can tell someone's taking the first
shot of this stuff like it's one of
those liquors that you don't see in your
face you don't see the ads some of the
other major brands put in front of us
we're not opening magazine and seeing it
we're not seeing it on every billboard
it's really the only place I have ever
seen a fireball ad it's on Facebook
almost every walk in the planet it seems
has a Facebook account at this point and
so they're hitting more people quickly
and most likely cheaper than they would
with any of those large marketing
campaigns every couple years something
else comes along and I don't think that
necessary fireball will have that
longevity but possible fireball doesn't
pretend to be the next great whiskey and
American culture I think for the purpose
fireball serves it's a pretty fun
product at the end of the day I want to
run a successful par and so if it's
something that my guests want it's
something that people enjoy but
something that I know is going to sell
and move I have no qualms with it
[Music]